Cause people are like talking about how like, cause I guess Bieber was like,
I don't like how MNM makes fun of all the young rappers. He was like,
I like the young rap degeneration of young rap. I guess some of it is okay,
but like who are you talking about? Kendrick Lamar. J Cole.
Or are you talking about Kodak? Black?
Are you talking about, you know what I mean? That Auto-Tune.
It sounds good. But like
people say like it's corny to rhyme all the. I was like,
a lot of these rappers would just say a bunch of fast all together and it's
corny, corny or than
my girl thought my pool was an ocean. Oh, corny.
Or than that
corny or than a Kodak, black dude
corny. Or then that cause no,
you know, Hey, you know, no,
you know, no though, you know,
none of what any of those rappers who are lyrical,
you know, they're not cornea. Then that look at,
look at, I know I look them up sometimes, but.
Cool.
Cormier than buying a
$180,000 diamond pacifier that Kodak black. I swear to God,
Kodak black is trolling me. At this point. I made fun of him talking to Lee,
looking like a Simpson.
He made his hair look yellow and triangular like a Simpson.
And now he's going to buy a baby pacifier thing, bro.
Are you trolling me.
Are you making fun of babies? Cause I will tell you right now.
We'll get to, come on, dude. Kodak black.
Are you trolling? Me bro. But yeah like.
Heartbreak
[inaudible].
Oh, Oh that's on a, that's an, a poster with a whales tail on it.
Oh you dude. You're saying lines that are in the mall.
You're saying lines that I can go into one of those stores in and,
and I could get like a, a, an Eagle soaring,
any luck.
She tells me by my cover. So you can read between my life.
There you go. Judge me by my cover. But you can't read between my lines. I,
you can go into one of those stores in the mall where they have the framed
posters of a, of a Puffin.
And you could see that under it excellence. You know, those God,
those stores in the mall. When I was, I swear to God, I was four.
I would walk by those stores in the mall and I would be like,
what kind of loss did he would ever buy? It's his businesses.
I guess I imagine being just like some lady with like kids and you walk by
one of those, what would they call like success?
What successories that's what they would call that.
Successories wow. The whole thing was cute.
It was a store in the mall. I don't know if they still have them. I mean,
but they would be, you could go buy framed prints of like a
whale breaching the ocean and it will be like,
you only see the success. You don't see the hard work,
you know, teamwork. And then, uh,
a bunch of people rowing a boat on like in like dusk
teamwork is the ability to work together toward a common vision.
The ability to direct individual accomplishment toward organizational objective.
Hey snore Fest, dude. No, come on.
Look what you got to read teamwork. Imagine,
imagine reading this and, and being like,
well, my life's different now teamwork.
Teamwork is the ability to work together towards a common vision.
The ability to direct individual accomplishment towards
organizational objective.
It is the fuel that allows common people to attain uncommon results.
At the end, it should just go F R R R T for a fart noise.
And then they take the picture of the people just rowing and.
This is Kodak black right here.
Teamwork is the ability to work towards a common vision.
I love when these dumb rappers just try to get like all it's
so funny, do these rappers would be like, you know, this album,
they basically just, you know, I had to speak with the I was going to,
you know, it would be like, like ludicrous would do this.
I meant to say, I mean, ludicrous is older now, but he would be like,
you know, this album was really about what it's like for me,
you know? And uh, so that's.
It's basically,
and then it would just be a song about cars.
These rappers are unreal. You know, this is really more about my life.
This album, this album is about basically what I'm talking about in my life,
where you know, what's going on in my life. And if you don't like it,
they always act like, and if you don't like it, you know,
that's just me speaking on. What's my truth, doc, if you don't like it, then,
then that's on you. Anyway, here we go.
Oh yeah.
They got so much money. You can't stop that. Oh really?
You know what I mean?
I just basically it's like, Oh, are you kidding, man?
Legendary. He, Oh, that's a joke one, right? No, no.
He was not a practical joke nor was he a fool,
but he was determined determinedly original and had a vague and modest idea of
himself as a legendary figure. No, that's not. That's gotta be a joke. One
it's on successories.com
Create your own. Oh. And now they have a create your own.
Okay. Well that's awful.
I want to get one of just my face like this.
Someone just do like this
and make it look like it's like dusk on my face and have it be like,
under it, be like, it will be like, it'll say some,
like,
You know what? Let's see. Let's see what, we just have one, somebody.
[Inaudible].
Be the bridge excellence. That's what I'll do. That's what I,
that's my favorite one having my face like this and then under it excellence and
then just under it, right. Something like sometimes we are coming and farting
and then sell that at the mall, Dude. Hey.
Yeah. You know, rap is about my life, you know,
is basically if you don't like it. Um,
but we talking about the real stuff, you know,
the real stuff that's really like affecting us. Um,
and if you don't like it, then anyway, here's the stuff.
Now you thought I was just
[inaudible] act like y'all know it's the abominable hole, man.
Wow. The abominable hell man, Hey man,
the abominable hell man and are out there getting like
canceled. Cause they worked for Pepsi and they're like, well, you know,
women make better nurses. And then I was like, what?
Cancel him, cancel that. And then you got to.
Y'all know it's the abominable. Oh man.
And this guy's got 50 mil and everyone's just like hoes.
I've got hoe hoes in different area
area. Like the temptations are in it area. Hairy
and are out there getting canceled because they work for, uh,
you know, Kaiser Permanente. And he was like, well,
you know, I can't cook as well as my wife because you know,
that's how she was raised. Cancel that.
Barry Kaiser Permanente, by the way.
Act like y'all know it's the abominable whole man globe trot and the national
post man. But Dick dope man.
Neighbor, Dick a dope man. Ah,
dude, neighbor, Dick dope, man. Wait,
hold on a second. Like he was really writing this down neighbor.
Dick dope, man. Hold on. Hey,
this was before we had the cell phone. You write everything on. Here we go. Uh,
abominable home, man, neighbor, Dick dope, man.
You know, cause they say neighborhood dope, man. Right.
But you could change it to Dick abominable snowman cause
abominable home, man, I go together and the neighbor hood, we can't think of,
I mean, not the really Raza hood, but you could just put Dick in there
anyway. Get a plane as some hoes unless you do a video. Um,
unbelievable dude area. I love,
I love Nate dog, dude. I love it.
I mean.
Crooned bro.
And he didn't give a what he was crooning about too.
I got in your eye.
I got come in your eye high.
And then he would back it up and be like [inaudible]. Um.
Right here in this part, right.
Area seven
(744) 477-2577.